welcome to this video's meet our 08
maybe Knight f3 for change what is this
three and a half out of five and I got
against that guy probably will get a
default can opening anyway yeah the semi
tower people really follow the top level
games that's a national sorry a
fashionable opening nowadays quite
surprising that this came back into
fashion but um yeah games by Crom Nico
of the German yeah can you say in German
number one and I'm not I don't think
he's listed under Azerbaijan yet um
Coleen I ditch he played a couple of
good games with it as well yeah rupee
one that's a slightly eccentric move but
it's interesting black takes on c3 my
rook is well positioned and that kind of
asked black the question what is next
movers okay h6 yeah of course and it's a
move you can play so lucky for now on is
that rubbish let's do it don't think
about it for too long
yeah the eternal question in this kind
of position is what about the Jeep on
can you push it should I push it should
I put it quickly yeah that's a good
question let's push it push the pond
it's probably probably right so now i
can play something like 95 that's a
that's a benefit really of them rook be
one move that something like bishop f6
is not in the diagonal but Bishop f5
will always hit the rook that's a bit
better than annoyance that move can I go
no not really t-6s no option Bishop to
e6 okay okay i just go okay one keep it
simple a non-threatening d6 winning the
exchange
yeah so 96 for that passport I think I'm
going for that it's not so easy for them
to get around to capture it and it will
always be a nuisance I hope and I
playing quickly I already tried to play
a bit quicker to not get into that huge
time problems yeah maybe that's also
reason why the quality of my moves are
sir sometimes really yeah really lacking
that may be true that that adjustment is
not really sinking in correctly at the
moment I don't know
so now I'm ready to invade on the
seventh-ranked things like to hang yep
and over on the seventh yes Bishop b5
but I was thinking Brooke g6 keeps this
under control hmm okay if I take it he's
got rookie one as a possible counterplay
that's true but if i take if i take it
no it's not a good idea bad idea
actually I don't really wait if I go
back if I just go back I'm threatening
to take it and place his several and
that would actually um yeah basically
promote the whole thing yeah but I
wonder rook okay I can always go rook 27
but that's not working
shake
Roxy one is God look see Sam
you
Luke c1 Roxy seven I wonder where then
move the rope he cannot take it but I
don't have a particularly great rock
move
well maybe I don't have anything better
that's maybe just the case it's not bad
just that I was hoping to have more
Keeney 737 oh I forgot about that one
completely ah and he's got King e7 and
I'm losing that porn right thats that's
brilliant our kind of rubbish is mad
yeah okay he's got King d6 he can
actually play that for an advantage
unbelievable okay i can check him then
1d aid
let's not bad but show Tempe Weiss if
that was a good decision time warning
and their point is very quick
hi this is losing in many ways rook a
five as well ok said still losing ok
black for fits on time I didn't even pay
attention to that ok well it's a benefit
off playing quick I and sometimes
windows ridiculous time games I was
really just trying to defend this to a
draw which I managed now I was happy to
get the headset from that completely
completely lost position huh but I'm
really more interested in in this kind
of part of the game because check around
here I have to I'm just I just I should
be better with that porn but somehow it
didn't materialize maybe this wasn't a
good idea yeah probably up t6 is just
not good I mean ok it's not like I don't
have a problem or anything i can do this
which I saw but it's just that I don't
get any way I am he can always go back
here is not threatening because of rooks
you born but but what is my next move I
can repeat moves I wanted to play for
something and this is probably just
rubbish brooksy seven it's just a move
that I did not take into account down
and from here you just played it well I
mean and sheer black ass winning of
those pawns are just far too quick don't
really know how how it it was not losing
so
some King it's probably losing a tempo
or something here the engine gives that
as a wind just watching with the King
like this no no this is actually play
like I can push through wait wait wait
wait set to settle loss I ok the screen
before us probably but hmm yeah whatever
maybe you can draw somehow here with the
fortress Luke on a4a sir is a fortress
now anyway okay thats am not a serious
analysis yes I should have lost him and
here Here I am drawing I'm really
drawing yeah I really I really didn't
see that I was winning on time really
you some guys probably i will write a
you saw that i didn't see it i really
didn't pay attention i just was looking
for yeah trying to save this this look
and game which was happening fortunately
our winning is a joke of course anyway
thanks for watching